I do want to talk about how the f did
Donald Trump win that's sort of how
we're talking about it we're going to
look at some exit polls first but we're
also going to talk about what is
underlying Donald Trump's win and I
think that segment will make everybody
pretty angry now as far as the exit
polls Donald Trump was able to
consolidate support with but white
voters and I'll show you some of the
exit poll results from the New York
Times here
Trump was able to consolidate support
with white voters he did better than
predecessors among white voters without
college degrees whites with college
degrees already used to favor
Republicans and they shifted slightly
towards Hillary Clinton but Trump still
won that group we saw party support
shift dramatically at nearly every
income level and this graphic is so
fascinating and I'll zoom in on it just
a tiny bit lower income voters typically
tend to support Democrats and wealthier
voters lean more Republican but income
does seem to correlate with education
and this time around you will see that
from oh four to 2016 those with under
$30,000 a year in income move towards
the Republican those between thirty and
forty nine thousand dollars in income
moved towards the Democrats since 2004
that was also the move that we saw for
those earning between fifty and two
hundred thousand dollars and those
earning over $200,000 at one point they
started out in 2004 very Pro Republican
swung all the way back to actually be on
the blue side and then went back to
almost completely even in the in terms
of their support for the Democrat or the
Republican truly unbelievable the other
thing I want to show you is this CNN
exit poll data where we see that
compared to Mitt Romney's results Mitt
Romney won seven percent of the
african-american vote Donald Trump won
eight percent of the african-american
vote and Hillary Clinton won five fewer
points 93 for President Obama versus 88
percent of the african-american vote for
Hillary Clinton that has an impact and
very importantly Mitt Romney won the
support of 27% of Latino voters
whereas Donald Trump won the support
of 29% of Latino voters that may seem
like a small difference but when you
consider that there are more Latino
voters than ever before making any
inroads on the Romney numbers is a
really good thing for Donald Trump the
exit polls are telling us a lot here and
they are surprising in many ways yeah
they're telling us a lot but I think
where things really broke down is that
in very key counties in swing states
Hillary had smaller leads that Obama did
like Wayne County Michigan and
Philadelphia County and I think that is
where it kind of critically fell apart
you want to know what is the cause for
that difference because how could this
electorate have changed so much as the
same people who voted for Obama by four
points well it isn't it isn't it isn't
it isn't because of demographic changes
of course I mean the exit polls are
different that from the polls going in
weeks beforehand but there's just a
whole angle of how could pollsters have
been so wrong there may not be a bigger
shift in how polling is done than what
we saw this election and we are going to
talk about that and much more coming up
on the show I'm glad you're with us
although not under the best of
circumstances remember that at david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 you can get
those free david pakman show calendars
with your yearly membership back after
this